nos dicen que un grupo de tres amigos
practica para la competencia de
atletismo el grupo va a correr medio
kilómetro en total si cada uno corre la
misma distancia cuanto correr a cada
persona qué expresión podría representar
esta situación así que pausa en este
vídeo e intenten resolverlo por su
cuenta muy bien la forma en que pienso
resolver esto es que hay una cierta
distancia que van a tratar de recorrer
entonces en este caso es medio kilómetro
y van a dividir esa distancia entre los
tres amigos y así la distancia que cada
uno de ellos va a correr es la distancia
total dividida por el número de personas
que corren entonces una expresión que
representa esto es un medio la distancia
total que están corriendo dividida por
la cantidad de personas que van a
recorrer esa distancia dividida entre 3
y esa es la opción se aquí ahora
podríamos confundirlos un poco porque no
estamos acostumbrados a dividir un
número más pequeño especialmente una
fracción entre un número más grande pero
eso es exactamente lo que está
sucediendo aquí
estamos tomando la distancia total y la
dividimos entre tres amigos entonces la
distancia total dividida entre tres
amigos nos dirá que tanto debe de
recorrer cada uno de ellos hagamos otro
ejemplo
entonces aquí nos están diciendo que hay
algún problema que se puede resolver con
un medio / 7 dicen qué problema podemos
resolver con un medio / 7 y luego nos
dan tres escenarios diferentes que
podríamos intentar resolver así que
pausa en el vídeo y piensen cuál de
estos tres escenarios se puede resolver
con esta expresión muy bien repasemos
cada una de las opciones
carla pidió siete pizzas para su fiesta
de cumpleaños sus padres comieron media
pizza antes de la fiesta cuánta pizza
quedó para la fiesta muy bien qué está
pasando aquí ella comenzó con 7 pizzas
ella comienza con 7 sus padres comieron
la mitad de una pizza entonces restamos
la mitad de una pizza y eso nos dice
cuánto queda entonces esta es la
expresión que necesitamos para responder
a no esta expresión de aquí arriba así
que descartamos esto guillermo tiene 7
hamsters cada hámster pesa medio
kilogramo cuál es el peso total de los
hamsters bueno para calcular el peso
total comenzaríamos con la cantidad de
hamsters y multiplicaríamos esa cantidad
por el peso
cada hámster eso sería siete veces un
medio así que podríamos descartarlo
entonces es probable que se hace pero
asegurémonos de que tenga sentido juana
tiene medio kilogramo de cereal ella
divide el cereal entre siete amigos
cuánto cereal recibe cada amigo muy bien
ella tiene un total de medio kilogramo y
va a dividir esa cantidad total divide
el cereal equitativamente entre siete
amigos así que tomará esta mitad y la
dividirá en siete partes iguales para
siete amigos y obtener cierta cantidad
por amigo cuando se dé al obtendrá cada
amigo eso es exactamente la expresión de
ahí así que me gusta esta opción